are you going out with an NBA guy again
I was that your thing I like athletes I
like to be active um maybe you should go
with something Melinda I know heard that
story before
are you in love how long have you known
this purse who is the guy who is this
guy though I don't know anything about
this name is James Harden he plays for
the Houston rocket where do you meet
these basketball players you go to the
game no I don't actually like hanging
out as a game Kimberly through Kanye a
birthday party at the Staples Center so
kind of went to a game but we rented it
out and she had like all of his friends
and some athletes were playing is the
rap on you that you have a thing only
for black guys do you think you'd date a
white guy I would never say never but as
of now I've never been with a white guy
no kidding what do you think that's
about I think you don't like white
people I'm just racist towards what are
you racist doing I hate white people
myself so I'm with you on that and what
age did you realize you only wanted a
black man I don't know but I lost my
virginity at like really young how old
14 or 15 wow that is young really young
so I must have known it really right I
must've known early if I put Brad Pitt
in a room with you and you're both
single I don't think you're [ __ ] him
like he's a really good-looking guy
good-looking guy but not he's not black
know what I think I I mean I have to
feel out the chemistry of not saying
let's say you you're gonna room with
Britt but then I could probably [ __ ]
them you could [ __ ] them yeah you know
what [ __ ] Fred I say what I'm gonna do
at that for your new show I'm gonna
bring in Brad Pitt mostly keep [ __ ]
what a show that bring in Brad and I
will find on-air you goddamn right